in africa hundreds of millions of people
have not had a covet vaccine
but there is a small group armed with
coolers and white pickup trucks who are
trying to do something about it
and their mission will take them miles
from home
what are the roads going to be like um
for today the roads are terrible uh we
might need a bit of 4x4 driving okay
this is a vaccine convoy run by health
organization right to care who send
teams down battered tracks in the
eastern cape in south africa
the idea is simple on a continent where
only 17 percent have been vaccinated
it's time to bring the clinic to the
people
our arrival in lundini was celebrated in
song this is the first time villagers
have been offered a jab and everyone 12
and over was eligible
when we work together we do wonders
saying the children
yet the teachers seemed slightly less
impressed
why did you come so late after a long
time
not attending as early as the conflict
starts
it's a good question but jabs are
available in the nearest city
how difficult would it be for the
children and their parents to
to go to durban to to get vaccines
it could be too difficult because
they've been far away from us
that would be very difficult yes people
here are vulnerable to covid but they're
also afraid the fear generating vaccine
hesitancy
the effect is dramatic nearly half the
jabs delivered to africa
have gone unused
here nurse lubando tries to reassure a
group of youngsters
all these myths you hear it's nothing
like that she says
they said sometimes the government wants
to eliminate the
[Music]
because of the she pointed to her skin
we are too much
then the government wanted to you mean
you mean black people yes they said so
so they're trying to get rid of black
people
right
then we're trying to tell them that
there's no such are you guys sure you
are going to vaccinate
all of us
yes
you don't sound very excited
we all underestimated the level of
mistrust the fears of the use of social
media amongst young people to spread
misinformation hina brahmbat is from the
u.s development agency which funds this
program but if you get them to people
people are likely to get vaccinated so
we're finding higher uptake in rural
compared to urban settings in south
africa because these populations have
continued to have unequal or in many
cases no access um to vaccinations and
now that we're getting them to people
you can see
people lining up you know for
vaccinations you barely see this in
urban settings in south africa anymore
but it takes a lot of work to get people
vaccinated
right to care have to send their trucks
and their people into the hills
and it's a delicate business
and ask if she's had a jab but she won't
speak until they lay a few coins at her
feet
to their surprise the sangoma says she's
fully vaccinated
but there are some who don't want to
know about it
this woman said the first dose made her
sick
i said i'm done
[Music]
this is pretty typical is it she was
shouting and all that expressing that
she doesn't want to eat
so you know this type of situations you
don't know you just have to let them
slide
in south africa more than half the adult
population are still unvaccinated as the
country enters its fifth wave of
infection a wave that's sure to spread
through africa
but the continents unprepared and
millions unconvinced about the threat
they face
john sparks sky news in the eastern cape